all right ellie hey ellie where'd you
grow up where are you from i'm from
detroit i grew up in like the northern
most suburb of metro detroit
um and i basically stayed in michigan my
whole life so i moved around to a couple
of states or i'm sorry cities and then i
came back here michigan is a great state
it is most underrated yeah we were
talking about that yeah it's great tell
me about your family my family i have a
really great family um i had a really
good childhood both my
um parents were really successful and
when my brother was born my mom was able
to stay at home so i grew up with my mom
a lot my dad was around um
they're both very like driven people
and
they give us every
opportunity really that we ever wanted
and i'm really grateful for that and i
um
but it was tough a little bit like i
never had anything happen but my parents
were definitely tough on us and i feel
like i was such a s like i'm still such
a sensitive person that like as a kid i
was really sensitive and i sometimes
couldn't handle that and i don't think
um
like a lot of people knew that
um but my parents did they divorced when
i was 16. and it was like very
like i knew about it i like remember
talking to one of my friends at school
and i was like i think my parents are
going to tell me they're going to get
divorced and then they did
so you know they had a really good split
though like they're still like very
cordial um but i think
like being 16 and your parents divorcing
like you grow up a lot and like you see
your parents is this
like
they're not superheroes and that can be
kind of hard
so but it was my fan i have a great
family i love them a lot that's great
yeah
you went to school went to college yep i
went to college in um kalamazoo michigan
and it was a great experience you know
like any type of college experience and
then
moved back to metro detroit and then i
needed like a crazy life change so i
moved to you know 200 miles away to
grand rapids not that far but i needed
to kind of get away and find myself and
and i did that and then
i decided to move back here um
two years ago my stepmom has um cancer
and that just kind of made me realize
like i want to be by my family
so
so you struggle with eating disorders
yes i am i celebrated three years of
recovery july i don't know when it
started but i can say july three years
ago is when i decided
i'm not doing this anymore so um
yeah i
i think like most
women there's a lot of pressure from
society to look and you know act a
certain way glenn and doyle wrote this
book it's called untamed and i've never
related to something more she says in
like the first three pages she's like
women are are meant to fit in a box and
if you don't fit in that box you're
gonna have to compromise something and
i'm paraphrasing but
um
she's like and that's when i developed
an eating disorder because i couldn't be
a good girl forever and i think that's
like how it happened with me i had so
much pressure
to like look a certain way i grew up in
the
early 2000s when like tabloids were
really popular and you know paris hilton
and lindsay lohan
mary kate and ashley they glamorized
eating disorders and it was always like
oh she lost five more pounds like i
remember reading that in tabloids
so and i was never skinny like i was
never the you know skinny cute girl
so
it wasn't until like my freshman year of
college i went away i developed like
crippling anxiety like
when people are like yeah i couldn't get
out of bed in the morning that's how it
was like i could not get out of bed
and um
i just i i gained some weight and then i
came back from school and i was like i
don't i want to i like wanted to feel
attractive i never like desired
like attraction from men but like going
away to school like i realized like you
know a lot bigger pond than you know my
hometown so like i wanted to like lose
weight and like look good so i
decided i was gonna
cut out gluten so i did this gluten-free
diet and when you do that your your body
can't you know you lose a ton of weight
and realistically your body can only
last i think it's like 12 weeks without
carbohydrates
so i was like working out i really found
a love for working out i was doing a ton
of yoga i um
i wasn't eating gluten
and then i um
you weren't eating gluten or you weren't
eating carbs
both i basically cut out anything
related to gluten and then like i wasn't
eating like the gluten-free bread so i
had like no carbohydrates besides like
maybe there's plenty of carbs other than
gluten yeah there is um but that's how
it started was like i was going to cut
out gluten to eliminate like a lot of
carbohydrates and then it kind of
trickled from there so i um
then you know you plateau once you
you know lose so much weight
and i still was doing like a low carb
gluten free and
i i was like well i'm not really like
going to the bathroom a lot so i decided
to start taking laxatives
and i was taking those like a lot
because i couldn't go the bathroom and
um
so i was taking those and nothing was
really working and then i went away to
school
and you go back to school and like
things change you have a different
routine so the next like four like three
years of college i still was like kind
of doing these flux diets and
i feel like it was until i graduated
college and moved back home that like i
went from
disordered eating to like eating
disorder so
i was still gluten-free at the time
gluten-free carb-free whatever
and i
decided to do yoga teacher training and
during yoga teacher training it's
encouraged
and it's to be vegan cut out dairy even
cut out alcohol sex drugs everything to
have a clear mind
which
i don't disagree with but at that point
i was eating
no gluten barely any carbs no dairy no
meat nothing so
i don't even know what i was eating it
was nothing
so um
but then my body just like went into
overdrive like i was still focused on
losing weight
and then i finished yoga teacher
training and i started this other diet
because i was not i didn't look like a
yoga teacher i wasn't ripped you know i
was doing yoga twice a day and i didn't
look like this persona the instagram
people
so
i tried this this diet that was
basically like
a medical eating disorder you
you didn't eat anything and i don't want
to talk about that because it's
triggering for like
myself and just a lot of people but
it was and i i lost like 20 pounds and
then i did it again and i lost like more
weight and it just never stopped and it
was like i would probably
relate it to like
like the first time you like
if you're if you're taking opiates and
like the first time you like shoot up or
something it was like this oh my gosh i
got this like high and that's when it
went from disordered eating to like
eating disorder
and i i was just like done after that i
wasn't i don't even i can't even
remember like i feel like my my brain
was in such
like overdrive like it was working so
hard on nothing that like those months
those years were like a total blur
so
i at that point i was going through this
like vicious cycle where i would eat a
little bit and then i would
take these diet pills and i would be
like
like super i would get almost high off
of them because i had nothing in my body
and then
i would um i would binge because it was
like i didn't know what to do i was like
gonna pass out and then it would purge
and it was like i did this just round
and round and round it was exhausting
and
my boyfriend at the time he basically
said to me he goes
i can't be with you like you need help
like you can't continue to use me as a
crutch like you need to do something
and i i called it like when you start
recovery a lot of times you'll refer to
your eating disorder as ed like a person
like you're almost
saying like he told you to do these
things and i i wouldn't do that because
like in the thick of it i'm like i don't
have a problem like i'm just testing the
waters i'm trying to lose weight i want
to look good you know i'm not there yet
so um
i i called him fred i'm like well fred
my friend of ed like a cousin of an
eating disorder
and i i couldn't admit it and then i was
like
i something's wrong like i do have a
problem the fact that like somebody who
loves me was like
i can't be with you anymore like
you know you need help so
i
i didn't i never went to like rehab or
anything and i think i struggle with
that because i'm like
you know did i did like i did i really
have something but it was like no like i
had i had some problems
and i think it's like imposter syndrome
almost like we never went to rehab or
you didn't do any of these things and
you know like was it really that big of
a deal but i look back and it was so
i picked up i moved across the state and
i was like i have to get better
so i was eating i'm like tracking my
food i'm you know that's the first step
i feel like of recovery is like
okay like you got to be okay with food
you know with
i think eating disorders are very
similar to addiction patterns
and people don't really talk about that
but like with eating disorder recovery
when you go to rehab for drugs you just
stop taking the drugs and then you deal
with like the mental stuff that comes
with it
with eat with eating disorders you can't
cut out your drug you have to
learn to live with it you have to learn
to eat you know in a healthy mindful way
so i'm incorporating food i'm feeling
good about eating and eating all my fear
foods that scared me for like the last
10 years
and
then it's like the mental stuff really
kicked in
and it was like july three years ago it
was like i couldn't take it it was like
it was like
i just couldn't get out of my own like
mind and my body and i had all these
problems with work that were like really
taking me where i was like i'm going to
do something bad again because i was
really trying not to re relapse but i
was getting into those behaviors again
and i remember
like driving my car and i'm like
gripping the steering wheel and i was
like screaming
and i'm like i never wanted to die but
if i just
like ended this i wouldn't have to deal
with this anymore like i just couldn't
take the thoughts
so then i was like
okay i'm i love my parents but they
didn't understand what i was going
through
and that was really difficult for me so
i wrote them this letter and i was like
i can't talk to you until i get better
and like i cut out a ton of friends too
but and i feel bad for
doing that but i had to and if i didn't
i don't
sorry i don't know where i would be
um
but
so thank you
so i am
i remember like
hanging out with friends and i was like
in that mindset of like
i can't do this and i found some
nutritionist some holistic nutritionists
where i was living in grand rapids
and i remember i'm like you know with a
bunch of people and i'm emailing her i'm
like i can't do this i need help like
you know i can't get these thoughts to
stop and i didn't want to die like i
didn't want to you know hurt myself but
and like i wanted to live but i just
couldn't
i couldn't keep going
i i think she gave me
the best gift of all in recovery is
finding somebody who like
really related to you because i think
with like all my my girlfriends and
stuff it's so common to to feel weird
about food but like not have
issues with it
so
i started seeing like i really started
to take my recovery seriously and like
go to therapy and
like work with my nutritionists
like on a bi-weekly basis just to become
stable again and
it like it took
a long time to get there but it was like
it was finally in reach like after being
programmed for so many years by society
to say you have to look a certain way
and eat a certain way and if you don't
you're not you know you're not worthy
you're not valuable to society to like
literally reprogram my brain and be like
that's that's [ __ ] like that's
horseshit
so it took it takes it took a long time
but i'm
like really happy to to be out of that
and like thinking back and even like
talking through
the processes like
wow like i can't believe i was that
person you know you just come so far and
it's
you just feel really grateful
was social media a problem for you
totally i've deleted
instagram a hundred times
and yeah it was huge because one you see
like
people who that's not what they look
like and you don't know that until
you know they post like i was just
talking with one of my girlfriends how
like all these influencers are coming
out and saying like they're dissolving
the filler in their face but then they
find interviews where people were like
oh did you get any work done and they
lied and they said no so you have all
these young girls who now are like 16
looking at this girl like oh i want
those juicy lips and i want a tight
forehead who are literally 16 years old
saying oh well she has it but it was all
lie
so yeah yeah definitely like social
media is so unhealthy it's fake it's not
real
yeah it's a it's a real problem it used
to be just magazines but now it's
yeah and now it's like you know every
time i mean and i'm like really
conscious of it but i find myself in the
middle of the night waking up and
scrolling like what
you know like that's so unhealthy
and you're working yeah i work
yeah and drugs aren't a part of your
life
no not really i barely drink
and yeah no
you've seen therapists about it
yeah i um like a actual clinical
therapist he gave me and i like in the
moment i was pissed when he said that
he's like i don't think you have an
eating disorder problem i think you have
a self-love problem and i was like
i'm like [ __ ] that guy that's that's
what i think every every person with a
problem on my channel would
it's a self-club it's about self-love
because when so a really great when
you're struggling with self-love a
really great experiment
if you get a picture of yourself as like
five years old
would you say any or do any of the
things you've done to yourself to that
little per like that little girl and i
did that when i started all this i'm
like and it was so emotional and i'm
like oh my gosh why would i do that you
know if i had a daughter i would never
if she ever treated herself the way i
did i would i don't know what i would do
so
yeah it and it is it's a self it's a
self-love problem
whether it's drugs
you know sexual yeah problems whatever
you name it eating disorders i think
it's all
it's all about self-love well yeah and
you also see
society like i i mean you'll hear like
that girl like when somebody is like oh
i love myself they're like well you're
kind of full of [ __ ] like
who does she think she is like but i
mean i can say right now like i really
do love myself that's why i don't want
to hurt myself
you know but people can be like she's
really full of it oh she thinks she's
perfect there are different ways of
saying you love yourself yeah i mean do
you yeah like do you want the best for
yourself at the end of the day like if
you don't love yourself
you can't love another person you can't
take care of another person
and like
you started out alone you're gonna end
up alone and like the most importantly i
think you can't love your kids
unconditionally totally yeah which is
the real problem that everyone that has
a self-love issue is
you know that's where it stems from yeah
having a parent that didn't love them
unconditionally yeah i i think my
parents are really like they they
everybody tells me they're like
even dads will go to me and say your dad
really loves you like he really loves
you i'm like what do you mean yeah i
know he loves me i'm his child and like
same thing with my mom i just think like
with my parents like when i look at the
patterns of like food
they they were both like really active
people and super driven
and
like
in the early 90s and and like late 90s
and 2000s like everybody was on a diet
and like i remember being little and i'm
like i like telling my parents i'm like
i really don't like my body
and it was like well just like change
something about the way that you're
eating and now as an adult like knowing
this and my parents like i they really
do love me and care about me and i don't
mean to like rip apart their parenting
but if my kids said that to me i'd say
all right let's go in front of the
mirror and talk about what you love
about yourself what you might not like
your tummy but you have beautiful hair
beautiful eyes and i think that's what i
needed as a kid and i think i didn't get
that
but
yeah it's it's tough
how old do you know i'm 28 you're 28
yeah so you still have plenty of time to
i love have
yeah i have a whole life to live yeah
and i think like when i think about
recovery
i've been fortunate enough to to go a
lot of places and like i kick myself
because i remember i went to paris and
like belgium and when i was doing like
when i was in the thick of all this i
wouldn't eat a croissant or like a
belgium waffle i'm like how stupid is
that like you let something so
ridiculous control your life that you
were in
some of the coolest cities and you
couldn't enjoy food now i'm like i look
at my plate when i eat and i'm like i
have all these beautiful colors and
textures and i'm like that's like what
brings me joy now but before it was like
i was so terrified
to eat anything outside of my norm are
you happier now
hell yeah i'm the happiest i've ever
been
and again it's self-love because when
you're in that state of mind
it's
you're self-sabotaging yourself because
you don't you don't love yourself so you
don't want the best for yourself so i
made like stupid decisions or i dated
the wrong type of people because i
didn't feel like i deserved love i mean
if i'm not going to give it to myself
somebody else isn't you know
so yeah yeah i'm i'm really happy i mean
and that's the thing is happiness you
see online is like it's constant it's
totally linear
but if you understand that like this is
happy you appreciate sad and then when
you're sad you go oh i'm gonna be happy
again. so it's just ebbs and flows
what are you afraid of
i've been exploring this being average
but then i'm like okay what is what is
average who's defining that if i get on
social media
and i scroll through and i'm like these
are not average girls or these aren't
average people
you know i
i mean it's just it's a perception so i
think i think maybe that like living a
mediocre life like i want to do
great things and like i wanna yeah
that's just your personality yeah i'm
the same way
i wouldn't call it mental illness i
would just say it's that's my little
quirk yeah yeah we all have something
yeah we do
but i uh yeah i think just living living
a mediocre life not not fulfilling
the gifts and talents that i was given
so the rest of your family there's no
similar
disorders like this um my aunt had a
really bad eating disorder my dad's
sister
and she do you think some of it might be
something you inherited or genetic or
your brain chemistry yeah we we talk
about it i think it's some of it can be
hereditary but like
based on other people in our family it's
also what you just said the fear of
being average yeah yeah being mediocre
nobody wants to be mediocre
um yeah so doing well a lot of people
with eating disorders they're
perfectionists
they're typically introverted but
want to be extroverted because that's
what you know people want them to do but
yeah i mean there's a there's a huge and
that's like what i still struggle with
is
you're not perfect i mean everybody
knows that like nobody's perfect but
you struggle with that because you are
and you want to please everybody i'm the
first who will sacrifice
anything i'm doing for somebody else
just so they can have like you know like
a moment because i'm like well i want
them to you know be okay and like it's
fine if like you know i'm in the shadows
and but then if i do have to
like do something i'm gonna make sure
it's the best thing you've ever seen
because i don't want to let somebody
down
but nobody cares that much so
what advice would you give to somebody
who is
struggling with this
that i think a lot of my recovery was
like i'm not that skinny like people
don't think i have an eating disorder
like
you
and like i'm like i'm not that bad like
it could be worse but i think your
feelings are valid and if you feel like
there is something wrong there probably
is
um
and like you don't have to be
like 99 pounds to be a prop like for it
to be a problem like there are people
who are quote unquote
overweight who are way off than the girl
who or the guy who's 99 pounds
so i think like if you feel like if if
you
are saying like i'm not happy and like
something does not feel right like your
story and your feelings are valid and
you need to
seek help or get a group of people who
are going to honor that
do you have any regrets of things that
you wish you had done differently
i don't think so
like i think it's really cliche to be
like oh i don't have any regrets because
like
you know everything that happens in your
life like that's the way it's supposed
to happen so
no i don't i don't think i have any
regrets
i just like wish i would have
faith this out sooner yeah like before
it was too much
what would you say is the most important
lesson you've learned in your 28 years
oh there's a lot
that's a good answer um i think
the greatest love affair you'll ever
have is with yourself
i think
when you this is the most important when
you shift your mindset from why is this
happening to me to what can i learn from
this your life will drastically change
when i did that is when i got better i
take responsibility for it yes you're
not a victim not not
most of the responsibility all of it all
of it yeah totally because at the end of
the day like i got myself yeah for
everything everything and if it's
somebody else's fault you take
responsibility for having that person in
your life yeah exactly and it's more of
like how do you it's how you react to a
situation and
yeah like i got myself into this mess so
who's gonna get me out
me and that's that's what it took me a
long time to learn it's like oh like you
know if i that my therapist is gonna do
it or my boyfriend's gonna do it no i'm
responsible for my own life and if i
want it to change i have to do it and
happiness it's not easy like it's not
easy every day to wake up and say i'm
not going to do those things i used to
do it's so much easier to to go back to
that but it is it's difficult to put the
work in and i've told a lot of my
friends that who struggle with other
things i'm like if you think that like
this just came to me one day and i woke
up that's not it i wake up every day and
i say i'm going to put the work in
because i refuse to go back to that old
person that person's dead and gone i
acknowledge her but if i'm moving
forward no i'm a different person and
i'm going to keep going down that path
excellent ali thank you so much for
sharing your story thank you wish you
the best of luck thank you thanks
you